l'état pousse son avantage ou ce qu'il
pense être son avantage en donnant deux
types de moyens
le premier c'est pas l'état qu'à
inventer les drones il est même très en
retard sur cette affaire moi je
préférerais que l'état ils investissent
dans des caméras piétons pour l'ensemble
des forces de l'ordre avec obligation de
les brancher en permanence transfert
immédiat des données et capacités de
contrôle par un organe - incestueux et
plus efficace que ne l'est aujourd'hui
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale ou de la gendarmerie
nationales pas parce qu'elles ne servent
à rien mais parce qu'elles sont très
efficaces pour les punitions interne
pour des exactions interne au
fonctionnement de l'ordre est beaucoup
moins légitime ou en tout cas acceptable
pour la société quand elle s'occupe de
la confrontation entre l'état ou en tout
cas les policiers et les gendarmes et
les citoyens et puis deuxièmement le
drone il existe il n'a pas attendu la
police est donc la décision des
instances les juridictions
administratives étaient un appel à la
législation est donc cet appel a été
entendu par le législateur après est-ce
que la manière dont le législateur
répondent à l'appel de la juridiction
convient c'est probablement un sujet de
discussion mais le fait de donner un
cadre législatif me paraît extrêmement
important de la même manière qu'il
fallait donner un cadre législatif à la
loi sur le renseignement
il fallait donner un cadre législatif au
maintien en tout cas un cadre
réglementaire en tout cas clair au
maintien de l'ordre et donc chaque fois
on peut pas être à la fois en demande
d'un processus qui encadre les actions
des services de l'état puis se plaindre
que le car arrive on peut se plaindre
que c'est pas le cadre qu'on voudrait
mais il faut bien regarder ce qu'est
l'enjeu en la matière les drones existe
sans cadre législatif autant donner un
cadre législatif quitte à faire en sorte
qu'ils ne soient pas aussi invasif ou
intrusif que ce qui est contesté
aujourd'hui sur lequel il ya
effectivement un gros travail à réaliser
oui
[Musique]